mein name ist so garantiert das war
furchtbar ich weiß nicht was hier gerade
abgeht ich sitze in einem flieger und es
sieht nicht so aus als wäre das eine
stinknormale lande alles ist irgendwie
an der decke die ganzen klamotten die
ganze sache nicht mitnehmen wollte wenn
ich aus dem fenster gucke ist das war es
vom video bei der damen und herren ich
bin tot
ich versuche jetzt mal irgendwie hier
raus zu schwimmen hier steht get to lift
und des surface wie ich muss erstmal
luft atmen alter ich komme überhaupt
nicht klar hier also wenn ich dir nach
oben schwimmen sehen wir dass ich hier
dass hier alles voll mit wasser ist ich
bin hier auf ein ghetto lift und des
service ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau
wo ich hier hin soll aber anscheinend
ist sie irgendwo einen ausgang oder so
dass sich zumindest schon mal okay okay
hier muss ich raus da unten müsste
irgendwo das flugzeug sein mit dem ich
quasi unter hey leute was geht ab ich
weiß nicht was das hier vorne ist ich
dachte gerade dass wir irgendwie ein
mensch der hier auch schwimmen es ist
einfach nur ein stumpf einfach stumpf
weiter sehr gut sehr gut lukas du kannst
ein fighter von menschen unterscheiden
wir werden gleich um auf dieser insel da
draußen aber vor jetzt wollte ich mal
gucken was das überhaupt ist oder ob ich
überhaupt hoch konnte holte inter
eekholt
ich habe sogar schatten sieht crafting
value sind wir hier in minecraft oder
was ich drücke jetzt mal einfach so und
wir sehen schon dass wir jetzt hier
verschiedene sachen haben die wirk uns
quasi irgendwie kräften können ich weiß
nicht wie ihr ein messer brauchen aber
ich glaube das zeigt sie noch mit der
zeit ich habe jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal schwimmreifen ich würd sagen
damit gehen wir jetzt erstmal hier auf
die insel drauf genau hier heute und
jetzt kann ich wieder runter unter da
ich bin ein einsamer in kraft ist ein
tool steht da vorne wieder eingeblendet
wir haben erstmal ein stick den kann
jetzt hochheben jetzt habe ich einen
stick das sind ich und mein sticker und
sie fliegt weg von mir ich bin ich
wirklich komplett alleine auf der scheiß
insel mitten im niemandsland fall habe
die scheiße sind eher alberne freude da
die sind gestorben glaube ich beim
flugzeugunfall das coole ist ich kann
mit fast allem reagiert also ich kann
die pflanze ein kuscheltier young
countries
kann ich doch nicht mit interagieren
wir haben beim rollen tree kann ich auch
nichts machen dann haben wir hier noch
ein paar hole ich bin offener beide 19
schulen brauchen wir zwei steine ich
würde sagen der ist das ist auf jeden
fall ein großer stein hier vorne müssten
stein sein genau holt op gab da habe
hier den ersten stein und gucke ich
überhaupt irgendwo hier noch ein zweiter
stein nur kurz so rumliegt wir haben
krebs ist der krebs was geht ab minister
crepes dazu mir einen burger machen oder
irgendwie sowas schon meist ja also man
muss sich das mal überlegen ich hatte
ein flugzeug unfall und habe als
einziger überlebt und jetzt stehe ich
hier mit einer krabbe einer einsamen
insel hayward über leib geist und wozu
verdammten mutter was ist eine hüllen
mutter haben wir noch ein stein meine
damen und herren das heißt cook den
antrag ab jetzt gehen wir das crafting
den möglichen of stone schule wir sehen
das tor der backpack ich habe ein
backpacker für das eine louis vuitton
tasche alter bisher bin ich echt
begeistert von uns wir haben stone tool
ich habe den stick wir haben hier live
treff und wir haben eine in der tüte wer
kennt es nicht man ist auf eine einsame
insel mitnehmen das ist trotzdem hier
meine damen und herren es müssten noch
irgendwo ein schwamm rumliegen dann
haben wir spongebob ist der kreis schon
wieder unsere nächste aufgabe ist es
kräfte rief ein live das heißt wir
liegen wieder auf c gehen immer so ein
bisschen durchgefallen live genau dafür
brauchen wir einen lustig den habe ich
schon lessing 0 von 1 was ist denn
lessing aber das müssen wir erst kräften
ich habe keinen plan wie ich den stick
pack oder wie diese leafs irgendwie
anstatt kriege aber irgendwie muss doch
hier muss auch hier ich bin ich bin ich
bin ein baum arme trieb es den neuen
apple watch es ist 13 uhr 40 am 17
dezember wir haben bisher 0 tage
überlebt die die zeit geht tatsächlich
sehr sehr schnell voran wo kriege ich
verdammte blätter hermann das kann doch
nicht wahr sein und dieser zeit kann er
nicht auch mal weg hier also auf f gucke
ich auf die uhr c ist minecraft xy
das hier sieht doch gut aus ich weiß nur
nicht ob das diese vorteile hier sind
weil wenn ich hier darauf bin ich bin
jetzt ganz oben wenn ich jetzt drücke
kann ich nicht ein
da ist mein arm einfach mal einen bleibt
drin wo in gottes namen kriege ich viel
bumms hierher alter hier lessing da
libris liefert reis hat überhaupt
weitere sleeves heißt faserige blätter
also blätter die sondern so ein bisschen
nicht so ganz dicht sind also die hier
um ein schatten von gottes namentlich
diese beschissen von dahinten vielleicht
schon schön die eigentlich so ein
bisschen wie urlaub gerade nur das ist
irgendwie auch nicht wie urlaub ist
hey das war eine supercoole aussage mal
wieder eine ewigkeit später wir sind ja
schon fast von der insel angekommen
ich weiß nicht genau was das da vorne
sein soll dass sie irgendwie aus wie so
ein boot sein kann es mal ein bisschen
ruhiger faden tag leute ibs kontrakte
ich wollte mal fragen ob ihr irgendwie
favorite ließ oder so für mich am start
weil ich habe die open water fakt ist
dass denn wir schauen wir auf die uhr es
ist 17 uhr 16
das heißt wir sollten uns jetzt mal
wirklich schneller oder sich aber schön
aus wir sollten uns jetzt mal ein
bisschen beeilen das gebiet nach
freibrief aus also kann ich klettere
doch den schweißgeruch heidfeld ich
jetzt auf dieser insel gefahren bin
wurde mir zu sehen das ist ja auch nicht
die blätter gibt hier hört krabbe hier
ich habe einen streifschuss es muss doch
irgendwo hier diese verdammten blätter
geben small screen kann ich auch nicht
abbauen bei bruce lees guckt euch mal an
wie die aussehen das sind einfach so als
solche solche blätter so und jetzt glaub
ich lang und wo sind die man direkt
wieder an da hab ich nehm das man
einfach mit jetzt meine uhr leuchte
zumindest schon mal im dunkeln freilich
habe wirklich überhaupt kein plan wo ich
die scheibe riss ließ herr krieger das
hier ist ein prima wieder ich muss
einfach nur solche wie nehme ich solche
blätter mit ja jetzt gerade raus gefühl
dass ich mit champions inventare greifen
kann das heißt neben meinen sound wohl
habe jetzt hier sondern so ein kleines
ding vielleicht kann ich jetzt hier mit
irgendwie die blätter abschneiden jedoch
nicht um
doch ein kokosnuss schild alter bleibt
doch ihr okay okay die kokons habe ich
jetzt auf die dinge jetzt kann ich in
rente gehen kann die kokosnuss nehmen
und jetzt kann ich die kunden kann nicht
die welche trinken man nicht
funktioniert wir freuen uns dass ein hai
ist das
ja ich habe erfahren dass sich hier mehr
ein herumtreibt
und ich habe es nicht mehr hingekriegt
mir ein scheiß messer zu machen
das war jetzt wieder erste part von
stranded die wenn ihr noch einen zweiten
plan haben wollt dann lasst mann vettel
schreibt mir die kommentare
luca ist oder das wasser ziehen
das war es jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]